Musik
Musik Musik Musik Musik Musik Musik Musik Musik Geil!
Ja, das hat funktioniert.
Steffen Teitzler hier, hallo. Lass mich noch mal einen Schluck Gären-Gerben-Saft nehmen, bevor wir anfangen. Ah, ist das gut, da kommt man so richtig in Stimmung. Herzlich willkommen, sehr geehrte Damen und Herren! Wenn ihr in Stimmung kommen wollt, dann habe ich für heute euch den richtigen Mann an Bord gezogen, in unserem Traktorstrahl, Stefan Torres. Genau, das ist mein Name, herzlich willkommen zum Podcast UFO und natürlich, es war nicht zu verhindern, wer wieder mit dabei ist. Es klappt nie, es geht immer über den Stottern. Es funktioniert einfach nicht. Es ist kein anderer als Florentin Will am Start, euch besser bekannt als Florentin Bill. Herzlich willkommen. Wir dachten, wir nehmen euch heute mal mit auf eine kleine Reise um die Welt. Es passieren ja so wahnsinnig viele Dinge auf der ganzen Welt. Und ihr hört ja immer, ich versuche immer schon so ein bisschen so einen interkontinentalen Flair mit reinzubringen. Stefan Torres, Stefan Teitz, Stefan Tite. Man ist ja so ein bisschen unterwegs. Ich finde es auch gut, dass die ganzen Namensgag nicht alt werden. Ich habe nicht das Gefühl, dass wir irgendwann mal am Ende angekommen sind mit diesem ganzen Namensgag und dass wir uns anderen mal mit falschem Namen ansprechen. Aber ich finde es gut, dass wir daran stick to the roots, sagt man ja, glaube ich. Ganz kurz, damit wir auf einem Nenner sind. Nicolas Schönrock hat bei Twitter geschrieben, die Spannung, wenn man auf die neue Folge von Das Podcast Ufo wartet und hofft, dass man bei dem Punkt Community erwähnt wird. Ich würde dich herum bitten, dass wir ihn nicht erwähnen. Nein, auf gar keinen Fall. Hat er nicht auch geschrieben, eine Woche Podcast Ufo ist wie eine Woche ohne Sex? Wo ich mir dachte, so what? Wo ich mir dachte, keine Ahnung, ich habe den Vergleich nicht. Ja, gut, dass wir schon mal unser persönliches Selbstbewusstsein einfach schon mal definiert haben. Müssen wir uns heute eigentlich auch noch Mühe geben, oder war das letzte Woche sowas wie ... Ne, heute keine Mühe mehr. Ne, wir haben keine Mühe mehr. Wir haben ja schon langsam den Schritt geschafft. Es gibt ja so einen Punkt, ab dem man einfach nur gut gefunden wird dafür, dass man überhaupt was macht. Und es ist eigentlich vollkommen irrelevant, was man macht. Genau, weil die neue Folge im Kontext der alten Folgen stehen, die im Durchschnitt ganz okay waren, meinst du? Ja, Bienen zum Beispiel. Guckt da wirklich jemand auf die Qualität des Honigs, gibt es da besseren Honig als schlechter und dann sagt man, es ist überhaupt schon mal geil, dass die es schaffen, überhaupt so ein süsses Zeug zu konstruieren. Ich glaube, da kommt niemand genau hin. Ich glaube, da gibt es auch viele Faulenzer, die sagen. Ja, oder auf der anderen Seite, wo wir gerade im Tierreich sind, ist mir aufgefallen, dass nicht alle Seesterne auch sternförmig sind, sondern dass manche einfach sehr seltsam verwachsen sind, aber trotzdem sagt man das Seestestern, weil der durchschnittliche Seestern ist sternförmig gebaut. Kann man auch mal sagen. Soll mal gesagt sein. Das ist ein guter Punkt. Habe ich eigentlich meine Seegurken-Story schon mal erzählt, warum ich Seegurken so hasse? Glaube ich nicht. Wir müssen auch nicht ins Anekdote abschweifen. Doch, aber ich bin gespannt, ich bin gespannt, wo diese Anekdote hinführt. Fangen doch mal an. Reicht doch mal an. Na, ich dachte, weil wir spezialisieren uns ja ein bisschen auf Pointen, und ich dachte, vielleicht drehen wir es heute mal um. Vielleicht versuchen wir heute mal eine Folge nur als einen grossen Setup, als eine grosse Feedline zu konstruieren. Ja, nur Feedlines raus und die Pointen könnt ihr euch selber denken. Genau, wir holen heute einfach mal nur Luft und was dann kommt, das müsst ihr euch selbst denken. Zum Beispiel, ich habe letztens eine Szene entdeckt, wo ich mir dachte, meine Herren, das ist eine geile Fiedlein für einen Gag, mir ist aber kein Gag eingefallen. Und zwar war ich einkaufen und habe eingekauft Süsskartoffeln und Nektarinen. Und habe ich die auf das Kassenband gelegt und dann wurden die abgerödelt und dann hat er gesagt, ach Mensch, das ist ja, was machen sie denn damit, Süsskartoffeln und Nektarin, das ist ja eine interessante Kombination. Wo ich mir dachte, hm, hat dieser Mensch bis jetzt immer gedacht, dass ein Einkauf auch gleichzeitig einem einzigen Gericht entspricht? Also dass alle Dinge, die man zusammenkauft, auch automatisch in ein Gericht zusammenfließen? Da dachte ich mir, das wäre eine gute Feedline, weil jetzt könnte man nämlich sagen, der hat bis jetzt immer so gedacht, das heisst, er musste auch denken, als jemand ...
Ja, aber was hast du auf diese Situation geantwortet, als er, also was hast du auf ihn geantwortet in dem Moment?
Weil, also ich weiss nicht, wie es dir geht, aber man hat ja schon immer das Bedürfnis, auch lustig zu sein in dem Moment.
Und das war ja auch die Frage, die er gestellt hat, war natürlich eine mega Feedline.
Ja, ich habe gesagt, ich mache Süsskartoffel-Pommes und die Nektarine esse ich so.
Also, glaube ich, mit das Unlustigste, was man in der Situation hätte sagen können, die Wahrheit. Sehr gut. Manchmal ist die Wahrheit auch ziemlich lustig. Weiß ich nicht. Hast du da ein Beispiel dafür? Nein. Nein, denn heute ist die grosse Folge der Feedlines. Wooo, Feedlines! Die das Podcast-Ufo-Feedlines-Folge. Folgendes. Ich wollte über folgendes sprechen. Die leise Problematik. Ja, es wird schon langsam zur Epidemie. Nein, es wird langsam zur Rubrik. Und zwar, ich habe mich so laut gestellt dieses Mal, hier mikrofontechnisch, dass ich glaube, man hört mich die ganze Zeit nur so Darth-Vader-mäßig mega übersteuert. Ich höre dich gut, aber meine Nachbarn auch. Ja, genau, das war der Plan. Meine Nachbarn haben mich auch, ich spreche ja auch sehr laut. Sorry, habe ich jetzt den Namen meiner Nachbarn gesagt? Müssen wir das zensieren jetzt eigentlich? Frau Koch? Ich habe noch niemals was zensiert in diesem Podcast. Vielleicht müssen wir das mal einführen. Doch, wir haben mal was zensiert. Tatsächlich, ganz am Anfang haben wir mal irgendeinen Namen rausgeschnitten. Ich glaube, der Name war Jan Böhmermann. Ich weiß aber nicht mehr genau, in welchem Kontext der gefällt. Ich weiß nicht mal warum. Irgendwas in der Richtung. Richtung. Aber durchaus heikle Information, das heißt nochmal Wiederkehrerbonus, sozusagen Backtracking, so wie wenn man bei einem Spiel. Hört euch die erste Folge an, da sind Informationen preisgegeben worden und jetzt wisst ihr auch, was in dieser Lücke, mit der ihr damals nichts anfangen konntet, gewesen ist. Genau, Stück für Stück. Übrigens, wir haben ein bisschen Serverprobleme tatsächlich. Wir müssen die Serverkapazität ein bisschen testen, deswegen bitte diese Folge einfach ganz oft runterladen, einfach zwei, dreimal pro Person immer wieder runterladen, wieder hochladen, wieder runterladen, wieder hochladen, ladet einfach irgendwelche Dateien auf unserer Website hoch. Wir müssen einfach heute mal testen, was ist möglich, was geht. Ladet einfach jede Folge, die ihr findet, 20 mal runter, ladet jedes Bild, das ihr auf der Seite findet, runter, copy-pastet den Text von unserer Seite, haut einfach, nehmt euch, was ihr kriegen könnt. Heute ist mal einfach Tag der offenen Tür. Nehmt euch von unserer Website, was ihr machen wollt. Kopiert einfach Teile der URL. Kann man auf fremde Webseiten was hochladen? Was sollen die denn hochladen? Wie? How? Naja, du kannst ja sagen, du kannst ja returnen. Bei iTunes kannst du sagen, zurückgeben bitte. Also, retour. Ihr könnt die Folge auch, das haben wir auch noch nie angeboten, ihr könnt uns die Folge natürlich auch zurückschicken. Und wir erstatten euch die kostenlose, das weiss ich auch noch nicht, ob wir das noch mal erwähnt haben. Also, falls ihr Probleme habt, falls euch gewisse Dinge nicht gefallen, sendet die Folge ruhig zurück, wir ändern das dann noch und händigen euch die Folge dann privat noch mal so aus, wie ihr sie gerne gehabt haben möchtet. Also, wenn ihr sagt, der Gag bei Minute drei, der hat nicht ganz getroffen, der war meiner Meinung nach noch ein bisschen daneben. Der hat mir nicht gepasst, dann schicken wir den euch in einer neuen Variation, in einer neuen Größe zurück, um mal in der Metapher zu bleiben, die von Anfang an ein bisschen schief war. Wie gesagt, ich habe mich sehr laut gemacht, du hast dich wahrscheinlich auch sehr laut gedreht und wir haben keine Ahnung, wir versuchen das diese Woche mal in den Griff zu bekommen, ansonsten weiß ich auch nicht mehr, dann lassen wir es halt auch sein einfach demnächst. Wir haben jetzt tatsächlich auch ein bisschen technischen Input bekommen, also wir versuchen davon ein bisschen was umzusetzen und dann glaube ich, aber wir haben ja auch die neue Rubrik Silent Corner, die kommt später noch, wo wir dann einfach mal 20 Minuten so leise wie möglich sprechen. Wo wir einfach nur versuchen, sehr laut zu denken, nicht im Sinne von laut denken sprechen, sondern wir denken einfach nur nach, angestrengt und ihr könnt, lasst euch an unseren Gedanken teilhaben. Wir assoziieren einfach. Oh, haben wir eigentlich schon mal das Assoziationsspiel gespielt? Nein, noch nicht, ich glaube nicht. Können wir das ganz kurz anreißen? Ich glaube schon. Wie gesagt, wir reißen es an, aber wir spielen es nicht zu Ende, dass es spannend werden könnte, okay? Genau, wir erklären nur die Regeln, aber machen es dann nicht. Nee, nee, nee, ich habe auch Bock. Also es funktioniert folgendermaßen, jeder von uns nennt einen Begriff, also du zum Beispiel Käse, ich sage Magnete. Magnete. So, und dann müssen wir beide auf drei ein Kompromisswort bilden, also was sozusagen auf der ultimativen universalen Wortskala zwischen diesen beiden Worten liegt. Also es kann, ne, also was dazwischen liegt. Also bei Magnete und Käse wäre es dann zum Beispiel Lautsprecher. Lautsprecher, genau. Und dann sagen wir beide gleichzeitig ein Wort, ich hätte jetzt zum Beispiel Mausefalle gesagt, und dann sehen wir, müssen wir wieder gucken, ob wir den Kompromiss aus Mausefalle und Lautsprecher finden. Ah, das ist interessant. So lange, bis wir an einem selben Wort angekommen sind. Und es geht darum, dass man es in möglichst wenigen Gründenafft, dass man sich gut überlegt, was sagt der andere, was könnte er machen und dass man möglichst schnell eine gemeinsame Mitte findet sozusagen. Das wird bei uns nicht funktionieren, weil wir beide denken vom anderen, dass er möglichst weirde Sachen macht, weshalb wir was ganz Normales sagen werden. Und irgendwann werden wir, werden glaube ich nicht ankommen, glaube ich. Also können wir es mal probieren. Wollen wir mal probieren? Wasser. Okay, dann sage ich Festival. Also das sind die Ausgangsworte, okay? Wasser und Festival. Jetzt müssen wir auf drei ein Wort sagen, der Kompromiss bildet. Okay. Okay? Drei, zwei, eins, Schlamm. Okay, Zwischenwort aus Schlamm und Durst. In drei, zwei, eins, Dracula. Wasser. Ich bin wieder bei Wasser. Nein, du kannst das Wort nicht nutzen. Okay, wir machen es nochmal. Drei, zwei, eins, Dracula. Was hast du gesagt? Biene. Okay, aber das ist schwer. Aus Biene und Dracula. Nee, ich weiss, das ist sehr einfach. Da ist was sehr Einfaches dran. Drei, ja, ja, ja, ja. Drei, zwei, eins, Spitz. Fliegen. Spitz? Die Zähne. Die Zähne und der Stachel sind spitz. Naja. Ja, komm. Na, okay, also jetzt haben wir... Ich würde es gerne abbrechen. Wir haben den Charter getan. Ja, wir bringen es ab. Denkt euch das Spiel einfach ...
Ich habe gerade eine Erdnuss verschluckt, es tut mir leid.
Ich snacke nebenbei ein bisschen.
Ich habe mir überlegt, wir snacken einfach ein bisschen.
Ja, ich wollte mir eigentlich, hatten wir mal wieder um 16 Uhr gesagt, dass wir anfangen wollen.
Komische Zeit auch.
Und deswegen dachte ich mir, esse ich einfach mal Mittag, während wir das machen, und habe mir was bestellt, was genau während der Folge gekommen wäre.
Hätte ich denn der Liefermensch, hätte ich hier reingebeten, hätte er den vorgestellt, mal kurz, aber nein, wir mussten das Ganze verschieben. Das habe ich jetzt schon gegessen habe. Oder eigentlich jetzt in so einer nach dem Post Mittagessen Phase bin, wo man eigentlich am liebsten nur schlafen würde. Ich war heute unterwegs, ich habe mir Gitarrensaiten gekauft, weil ich komplett die Kontrolle über mein Leben verloren habe und irgendwo noch eine Art Bedeutung herholen muss. Und das ist in der Musiktour. Und ich habe nur eine, also das war echt mega creepy, mitten in der Nacht, ich schlafe, ansonsten sind in meinem Zimmer kaum Leute anwesend, nur ich und Gegenstände. Und mitten in der Nacht reist die fünfte Seite von meiner Gitarre. Von der neu aufgezogenen Seite, oder deswegen, was was war der Grund, warum du ... Nee, nee, nee, das ist jetzt die Vorgeschichte, warum ich eine neue Sait gekauft habe. Das ist interessant, ein Prequel. Ja, und also mitten in der Nacht reist diese Sait, also ein wahnsinnig lautes Geräusch, plong, wie die ganze Gitarre klirrt und ich wache auf und denke, what the fuck ist hier passiert? Und dann, ein paar Sekunden später, fällt ein Buch aus meinem Regal auf den Boden. Ja. Und ich dachte, what the fuck, was ist denn hier los? Also ist das ein mega krasser Zufall oder handelt es das Schwingungsgefüge des Raumes auseinander? Wobei das Erste, was ich als Geist machen würde, ist glaube ich auch so Dinge wie Gitarrenseiten durchschneiden oder ein Aquarium, ein Loch reinmachen, dass irgendwie ganz nervige Dinge passieren. Oder mit Pflasterchen ins Aquarium werfen. Ja, aber auf der anderen Seite ist es... Ist es für Fischer auch so nervig? Auf der anderen Seite, Geister, meinst du? Ich glaube, Geister sind für jede Liebe, sind gleichzeitig nervig. Aber ich finde, ein Buch runterschmeißen ist sehr, da hätte ich aber auch gesagt, ne, komm jetzt. Ist ein Gähner, ist ein Gähner. Ne, das ist uncool, echt. Zumal ich mir dachte, Geister sind ja eigentlich deswegen relativ ungefährlich, weil sie dich nicht töten werden. Weil wenn du getötet wirst, wirst du selber zum Geist. Und kannst dem anderen Geist weg auf den Sack gehen. Und kannst ihn konfrontieren mit, was sollte das denn eigentlich gerade? Das heißt, er wird dich nicht töten, weil er nicht möchte, dass du zum Geist wirst. Das heißt, das Schlimmste, was du machen kannst, um Geister zu begegnen, ist, selbst zu sterben. Aber wenn sich Geister rächen, glaube ich, dann, die leben doch in so einer seltsamen Zwischenwelt, sagt man doch. Und wenn die sich gerecht haben, dann sind die ... Die leben in der Geisterwelt. Ja, gut. Das ist die gleiche Welt wie unsere. Na gut. Aber halt in einer anderen Dimension. Wir haben uns eine Art Thema heute überlegt. Ich weiß nicht genau, da gibt es keine Überleitung hin. Eigentlich doch, weil das Thema ist Schicksal und alles ... Jede Überleitung wäre besser gewesen, als die, die ich jetzt habe. Ja, ist dir vielleicht aufgefallen, dass das eine fucking Überleitung war? Ja, gut, Schicksal, alle sterben, sehr gut. Ich habe es bei echten Dornen. Nein, dass es halt gleichzeitig passiert ist, dass mein Buch untergefallen ist und die Gitarrenseite gleichzeitig gerissen ist. Warum? Was hatte ich das? War das Schicksal. Nee, nur die Seite war das Schicksal, deswegen bist du durchgegangen, hast du deine Seite geholt. Ja. Aber das Buch, wo ist das Buch? Da wollte ich noch etwas ganz anderes erzählen, dass ich bei der Tankstelle war, aber das können wir später machen. Meine krasse Tankstellen-Story haue ich später noch raus. Leute, da guckt ihr aber. Okay, ich hies auch kurz an, ich habe eine krasse Flüchtlingsstory zu erzählen. Bau, bau, habe ich mir aufgeschrieben, weil du mich gesagt hast, dich daran zu erinnern. Bleib bis zum Ende dran, ich werde sie erzählen. Aber wie gesagt, wir wollen ein bisschen über Schicksal sprechen, und zwar lag mir das Thema neulich sehr am Herzen, weil ich irgendwie war ich so ein bisschen down und dann bin ich mal wieder U-Bahn gefahren. Moment, hey, hey, hey. Ja, was denn? Warum warst du down? Was ist los? Weiß nicht. Ich habe so ein bisschen, ach, ich habe so ein bisschen so eine Phase gehabt, wo ich dachte, ach, kommst du nicht so richtig weiter in deinem Leben, du bist die Einbahnstraße. Aber warum denn? Du bist doch total weit in deinem Leben. War der Weg, den du gegangen bist, nicht vielleicht an der Einbahnstraße bis jetzt.
Und dann habe ich so ein bisschen weinend in der U-Bahn gesessen und dann habe ich Podcast gehört und dachte mir, das peitscht jetzt so ein bisschen auf, kommst aus dem Loch raus und hörst den lustigen Podcast an. Und dann habe ich mir, weil ich den Simpsons, den Family Guy Writer Alex Salkin ziemlich cool finde, weil er hat auch die ganzen Star Wars Parodien gedreht und der ist eigentlich ein sehr guter Autor. Und es war halt genau eine Folge, wo er wirklich eine Stunde lang über Versagen gesprochen hat und über Einbahnstrassen im Leben, über genau das, wo ich eben darüber nachgedacht habe. Und genau darüber redet er halt eine Stunde und war in einem Podcast eingeladen, den ich auch nicht kannte, aber es war ein Podcast, der sich nur darum geht, wie Leute versagen. Die haben irgendwie die zwanzigste Folge da aufgenommen über Leute, wo die eine Stunde darüber reden, wie sie versagen und was alles scheiße läuft. Und es war mega deprimierend und es war kein Gag in der ganzen Folge. Und deswegen dachte ich mir auch so, es ist irgendwie schon manchmal, hat man auch, wenn man gerade ein neues Wort gelernt hat, dann hört man das ja auch überall. Das sind ja diese Momente, wo man einfach, wo man denkt, das ist schon irgendwie ganz schön creepy, irgendwie ist die Matrix des Spiels, in dem wir gerade stehen, irgendwie kaputt oder so. Weil man ja schon das Gefühl hat, dass es alles dann für einen selber gemacht ist. Ja, stimmt. Also du glaubst an Schicksal. Nee, auf gar keinen Fall, aber es sind ja diese Momente, wo man darüber nachdenkt. Glaubst du denn an irgendwas? Ich glaube an Geister, ziemlich fest. An Geistern? An unkreative Kackgeister. Es fände ich auch gut, wenn man an eine einzige mythologische Figur glaubt, aber an alle anderen nicht. An Faun gibt es, bin ich mir hundertprozentig sicher, Faun, aber Engel, Alter, bist du völlig wahnsinnig, natürlich gibt es keine Engel. Es gibt nur Faun. Faun? Das fände ich auch ganz gut. Ja, Faun. Faun. Ich weiss nicht, was das ist. Ich kenne Pfauen, diese anmutigen Tiere mit den grossen Federkränzen, aber ich weiss nicht genau, was Faunen sind. Nein, schau dir mal das verrückte Labyrinth an. Sind Minotaurin Pfauen? Nein. Was sind Minotaurin? Ein Minotaurus ist ein Wesen mit dem Oberkörper eines Menschen und dem Unterkörper eines Tieres. Das ist das Gegenteil von einem Centaurin. Ein Centaurus ist ein Wesen mit dem Oberkörper eines Menschen. Ja, ich bin raus. Ich wollte nur was ... Also falls ihr euch gefragt habt, warum ich keine Freundin habe, ich glaube, das ist jetzt relativ klar geworden. Und ich kann euch den Unterschied zwischen Goblin und Gnom erklären, aber das ist vielleicht in der nächsten Folge. Jedenfalls habe ich dann darüber nachgedacht. Ich weiß nicht, hast du auch Grand Theft Auto gespielt? Und da war es ja auch so, wenn man ein Auto sich geklaut hat, dass plötzlich alle das Auto gefahren sind. Also bei Vice City zumindest in diesem einen Spiel haben alle das Auto plötzlich auch gefahren. Und es war irgendwie so ein Fehler in der Matrixwelt des Spiels. So, wenn man einmal ein Auto gefahren ist, haben das auch sehr viele andere Fahrer in diesem Spiel, haben dieses Auto auch.
Und so ist es ein bisschen, wenn man ein neues Wort gelernt hat, wenn man gerade über etwas nachdenkt.
Plötzlich sieht man sehr viel ... Einmal ein Auto gefahren ist, haben das auch sehr viele andere Fahrer in diesem Spiel, haben dieses Auto auch.
Plötzlich sieht man sehr viel von dem, woran man gerade nachdenkt, auch in der normalen Welt.
Das ist spannend, ne?
Selektive Wahrnehmung, ja.
Habe ich mal aufgeschrieben, wollte ich sagen, kam mir ein bisschen zu stümperhaft drüber.
Aber es ist das, glaube ich.
Ja, fand ich auch nicht ideal, aber war in Ordnung.
Das Konzept ist natürlich interessant, selektive Wahrnehmung, dass wenn man zum Beispiel gerade verliebt ist in jemanden, dass man dann den ähnlichen Haarschnitt oder ein ähnliches Auto überall sieht.
Dass man den selben Haarschnitt trägt.
Ja, genau, dass man immer mehr zu der Person wird, in die man verliebt ist. Es wird für die Person immer mehr Orgut zu verliegt.
Florentine schlägt schon wieder ein Kleid.
Ja genau, was, was?
Die Ohrringe, die stehen auch nicht so gut. Die Fingernägel, hör auf, die anzumalen. Es ist schon wieder eigentlich gut, dass wenn man Menschen nicht so gut kennt, dann geht man davon aus, sie mögen ja zumindest sich selbst. Sich selbst mag man ja eigentlich und deswegen versucht man möglichst ähnlich so auszusehen wie die Person selbst oder trägt ein T-Shirt mit dem Kopf der Person drauf. Ja, genau. Ich glaube, das ist ein gutes Commitment. Ich habe eben gedacht, woanders hin mit dem Satz, was mir aber auch so geht, wenn die Leute zum ersten Mal sehen, dann denke ich immer, trage ich jetzt das, was am ehesten zu mir passt oder was am ehesten mich auszeichnet. Weil eigentlich sollen die mich ja, aber nichts, was ich trage, ist, glaube ich, irgendwas, wie ich mich beschreiben würde, weil ich mich einfach nicht mit irgendeinem Äusseres identifiziere. Das ist schon ganz interessant, aber man will irgendwie so aussehen, wie man durchschnittlich aussehen würde. Aber würdest du dann auch sagen, also angenommen, du siehst eine hübsche Frau auf der Strasse und sprichst sie an natürlich und sagst dann, hey, pass mal auf, im Vorhinein, ich sehe normalerweise wesentlich besser aus, weil ich nicht irgendwie mit Flipflops und Jogginghose durch die Gegend laufe und weil ich nur zur kurzen Tankstelle wollte, um mir ein Twinkie zu kaufen. Das mal vorneweg. Beefy-Roll. Folgendes. Magst du lieber normale Beefy oder Beefy-Roll? Hast du gute Fragen? Mir ist aufgefallen, dass im Leben etwas fehlt. Und zwar, das kennt man von die Sims. Dinosaurier. Es fehlen Dinosaurier und diese Pluszeichen, die sich bilden, wenn man mit Menschen redet und das Thema ankommt, wenn man selber ankommt. Dann gab es bei den Sims immer oben diese kleinen Plusse, diese grünen Pluszeichen, die sich gebildet haben, wenn die Chemie gestimmt hat, wenn man Fortschritte macht in der Freundschaft. Und das vermisse ich einfach in meinem Leben. Ich vermisse, wenn ich auf der Strasse jemandem anspreche, die Pluszeichen oben.
Ja, weiß ich nicht.
Wir glauben, ich wäre bei dir nicht so ertragreich, muss ich ganz ehrlich sagen.
Du meinst, weil sehr wenig Pluszeichen, nur sehr viele Minuszeichen.
Ich glaube, mir wären sehr viele Geteiltzeichen, wo niemand genau weiß, was es bedeutet.
Das ist schon wieder eine dieser Folgen, wo wir nicht genau wissen, wo sie hinführt.
Und ich glaube, jetzt ist gerade so ein kleiner Punkt erreicht, wo wir die erste spannende
Anekdote raushauen sollen, wo wir eben drauf geteasert haben.
Und ich bin gespannt, was deine Geschichte zu bieten hat.
Welche Geschichte? Die Tankstehen-Geschichte?
Die Tankstehen-Geschichte.
Ich war einfach nur auf dem Weg.
All right.
Okay, let's hear it. Okay, puh, mal gucken, was mir noch einfällt, um die ein bisschen krasser zu machen.
Ich war gerade auf dem Weg, um mir eine neue Gitarrenseite zu kaufen, weil ich mir dachte, wenn eine Gitarrenseite gut klingen muss, dann die fünfte Gitarrenseite, das ist die wichtigste Gitarrenseite, die E-Seite, die A-Seite, die muss gut klingen, einfach weil das dir wichtig ist. Und die muss besser klingen als alle anderen. Das heißt, alle anderen Seiten sind schlechte Qualität, weil die Musikladen fragen dich ja. Ist die A-Seite deine Lieblingsseite, fragen dich erst mal. Ja, meine Lieblingsseite ist die D-Seite, aber die wichtigste Seite ist die A-Seite, das ist klar. Und die fragen dich ja im Musikladen nicht, hey, möchtest du die Lawrence of Arabia oder die Franzonetti-Gitarrenseiten, sondern sie fragen sich, willst du die guten oder die schlechten haben? Natürlich mit dem Hintergrund, dass du natürlich… Die haben dich total in der Hand. Leute in diesen Fachläden sind wie Comicbuchläden, wo ich auch noch nie drin war, aber die haben dich einfach komplett in der Hand, weil die wissen alles und du weisst nichts. Du weisst nicht, ob die da Dario besser sind als die Konglomerati-Seiten. Das wissen die. Und wenn die Leute sagen schon, willst du die Guten oder die Schlechten, dann haben die dich komplett in der Hand. Die haben die Kontrolle über dein Leben. Ja, was soll man da darauf antworten? Willst du die Guten und die Schlechten? Was ist denn das für eine Frage? Nimm mal die Mittleren, nimm immer die Mittleren. Ja, weiß ich nicht. Genau wie mein Vater neulich sagte, du Junge, Sohn, Sohn, du brauchst Winterreifen. So, und ich darauf, ja, ich kenne mich, keine Ahnung, was, was, weiß ich nicht. Dann sagte er, ja, dann machst du wie ich immer, ruft er an und lasst dir die Guten sagen, die Schlechten sagen und nimm das Mittelding. Die haben dich auch komplett in der Hand, anscheinend, also mich sowieso schon mal, aber anscheinend muss man einfach die Mittleren nehmen. Aber das ist ja der Punkt, dass Sie die Mittleren nicht nennen, dass Sie nur sagen, die Guten und die Schlechten. Wie ich tatsächlich auch Zeuge eine sehr awkward Diskussion war, wie ein amerikanisches Pärchen von mir in einem Supermarkt gefragt wurde, wollen Sie die grossen Tüten oder die kleinen Tüten? Und dann haben sie gesagt Medium. Und dann hat er in der Kasse gesagt, wenn es Medium gäbe, hätte ich Medium gesagt, es gibt die grossen und es gibt die Kleinen. Oh, jetzt raus aus dem Land! Und dann meinte die Frau dieses Pärchens, die natürlich sofort auf Aggression gestellt hat, so von wegen, na ja, wenn ich nicht sage Gross, dann meine ich ja wohl automatisch Klein. Und der andere, der Kassierer meinte, wollen Sie jetzt klein oder wollen Sie gross?
Und dann sagte der andere, wie gesagt, wenn ich nicht sage gross, meine ich klein.
Also wirklich sich in sein eigenes Argument so ein bisschen verrannt, so geht nicht hundertprozentig auf, aber man kann es ja mal versuchen.
Oft, Argumente werden oft besser, wenn man sie einfach nochmal und lauter sagt. Dadurch werden Argumente generell besser.
Und deswegen ist es dann tatsächlich zu einem Faustkampf gekommen, zu einem wilden Handgemenge und es ging nicht gut aus. Wo du dich wild dazwischen geschmissen hast. Ja. Was ist passiert bei der Tankstelle? Ich bin immer noch ganz... Naja, also ich war auf dem Weg, Gitarrenseiten zu kaufen, weil ich mir dachte, hey, was definiert mich eigentlich als Mensch? Was bin ich eigentlich? Sollte ich nicht eher Musiker sein? Also kann ich damit nicht besser, mich mit der Welt identifizieren, Musiker zu sein, kontemplativ in mich selbst gehen, die Musik wirklich zu leben, einfach mal das Bob's Burger Intro auf der Gitarre spielen, erfüllt mich das, kann mich das nicht erfüllen, warum nicht, warum soll ich ein unerfülltes Leben führen, wenn ich es doch könnte, warum soll ich nicht das Bob's Burger Intro auf der Gitarre lernen, obwohl es eigentlich ein Ukulele-Stück ist, aber ich mir wirklich nicht eine Ukulele kaufen will, weil ich mir denke, dann habe ich einfach aufgegeben. Nein, nein, nein, so würde ich das nicht sagen, ist schon sehr cool. Nein, aber man hat einfach verloren. Nein, naja. Wenn du schon mal, sag ich mal, wenn du, also ganz kurz, ich finde ein Leben mit ironischen Semikonstanten ist in Ordnung, aber ein Leben mit ironischen Konstanten ist nicht in Ordnung. Wenn du dir konstante Dinge ironisch kaufst, hast du ein massives Problem. Wenn du dir ein ironisches Tattoo machst, hast du ein Problem. Ironischen Bart trägst, hast du ein Problem. Wenn du spontan semi-permanente ironische Dinge tust, dann ist alles in Ordnung. Aber wenn du dir Dinge kaufst, nur weil sie ironisch sind, die du nicht mehr permanent ändern kannst, dann hast du ein Problem. Deswegen, Ukulele kommt mir nicht ins Haus, funktioniert nicht. Deswegen dachte ich mir, brauche neue Gitarrenseiten.
Und dann gehe ich so und komme an der Tankstelle vorbei und denke mir, ja geil, an der Tankstelle,
da gibt es doch immer so diese amerikanischen Importgüter, ja, Twinkies, Hershey Bars, Reese Cups, Take Five,
was der beste Motherfucking-Riegel der Welt ist.
Milka.
Da bin ich da reingegangen.
Milka, Erdbeerkäse, Cola, Pizza, gibt es alles an der Tankstelle. Und dann habe ich da drei Take-Fives gekauft, die jeweils irgendwie 2,80 Euro gekostet haben. Das ist jetzt schon die beste Geschichte, die du niemals erzählt hast. Aber es wird noch besser. Achtung, die Pointe kommt noch. Ich freue mich schon. Auch wenn wir heute eigentlich Pointenverbot haben, die Pointe kommt noch. Und dann habe ich die auf die Theke gelegt und dann meinte er, ja, sonst noch irgendwas? Also im Sinne von, habe ich getankt? Nein. Und dann meinte er, hat er mit so einem Blick, ja, 7,40 Euro. So im Sinne von, wollen Sie das wirklich für 7,40 Euro kaufen, drei Schokoriegel für 7,40 Euro? Und ich gesagt habe, ja klar, natürlich, das sind fucking Take Five. Das ist das, was ich will. Das ist das, was ich will. Ist auch gut, normalerweise beschwert sich der Kunde darüber, dass Dinge zu teuer sind, aber interessant finde ich es dann, wenn der Verkäufer sagt, Moment mal, stimmt das, sie bohr auf 50 für drei Riegel, wollen sie das wirklich kaufen? Ist das wirklich jetzt ihr Wunsch? Ja, dann merkt man auch so, dass in seinem Leben ein bisschen gewisse Dinge... Genau, wie an der Tankstelle mal war und wahnsinnig Hunger hatte. Und die haben ja nur irgendwie morgens so nebenan noch so Brötchen gebieten die an, aber sonst bist du einfach aufgeschmissen, dann bist du wirklich auf Bifirol angewiesen, das ja wirklich noch so das am sattmachendste in den Tankstellen ist. Und dann habe ich getankt und zwei Bifirol besorgt, XXL, die XXL-Variante auch, und die Kassiererin hat mich wirklich bestimmt zehn Sekunden angeguckt und dann abwechselnd die Bifirol und mich angeguckt. Also in dem Sinne, ist das wirklich ihr Ernst? Die wollen sie haben? Weil anscheinend kauft niemand mehr Bifirol. Seltsam eigentlich, die hatten nochmal eine grosse Hochphase in den 90er Jahren, da wurden die doch groß gehandhabt. Wir sind ja auch so Nineties Kids, oder? Ja, 90s, ich liebe die 90s. Glücksbärchis.
Was ich am meisten mag, ist
Kawabanga und
Pokémon-Karten. Und Yu-Gi-Oh!
Ohne Scheiß, ich habe eben
ein Video nachgeguckt, und zwar bei Stefan
Raab waren tatsächlich Yu-Gi-Oh!
Profis zu Gast, was ich wirklich
interessant fand. Das ist total strange,
das habe ich auch gesehen. Das fand ich wirklich interessant,
der hat lange nicht mehr so Gäste da, die mal nicht Promo machen wollen für irgendwas. Und dann einfach mal Leute, die einfach das Spiel erklärt haben, was ich ganz interessant fand. Und die verdienen wirklich Geld damit und haben Sponsoren, die haben Sponsoren, die die um die Welt fliegen lassen, um da mit Monstern gegen andere Monster zu kämpfen. Total interessant, aber wirklich auch eigentlich ein ganz geiles Spiel gewesen.
Trotz, ich will jetzt nicht wieder in diese Nein-Diskits-Phase,
aber wirklich ein interessantes Spiel gewesen, wirklich gut und durchleicht.
Ich habe mal in einem Podcast ein Pokémon-Kartenspiel gespielt.
Das war, glaube ich, so das Konterintuitivste, was ich je gemacht habe,
und das hat überhaupt nicht funktioniert von vorne bis hinten,
wo wir dann immer gesagt haben, so, ich spiele jetzt Punita,
die hat 60 Lebenspunkte und hat die Attacke Flammenschlag für drei Feuerenergie, 60 Schaden. Das hat einfach überhaupt nicht funktioniert, wenn man natürlich einfach nicht folgen kann in dem Podcast. Es gibt gewisse Dinge, die kann man in dem Podcast machen, wie zum Beispiel in einem Heißluftballon fliegen. Das funktioniert sehr, sehr gut. Und man kann sagen, was man sieht, das ist gut, weil da kann sich der Zuschauer vorstellen und man hat ein gewisses Gefühl für die Höhe. Andere Dinge, die nicht so gut funktionieren, Angeln zum Beispiel, das lässt sich schwer übertragen im Podcast.
Pantomime ist auch nicht so gut. Ich bin seit 30 Folgen jetzt schon am Start und mache wilde Pantomime und versuche meinen Gag nebenbei noch mit lustigen Gesten irgendwie zu unterfüttern, aber es kam noch kein Kommentar von euch. Also anscheinend funktioniert es nicht so gut. Du, mir ist was ganz komisches passiert. Ich habe einen Zebra-Tweet abgesetzt. Kurz noch die Twitter-Ecke. Ja, was war da los? Ich habe einen Zebra-Tweet abgesetzt. Twitter-Report. Und plötzlich kamen Follower, eine Menge Follower. Und ich dachte erst so, hey, hätte ich jetzt nicht ... Ich fand den nicht so gut, den Tweet, aber okay. Aber plötzlich kamen sehr viele Leute, wurden darauf aufmerksam. Man kann sich seinen Durchbruch nicht aussuchen, sage ich immer. Ja, das ist ein bisschen ärgerlich. Die Ärzte wollten auch nicht mit Männer sind Schweine berühmt werden. Und ich werde dann plötzlich mit so einem Zebra-Tweet berühmt, dachte ich. Im 30 Follower wurden es plötzlich, dann wurden es 50, dann wurden es plötzlich auch 1000. Was mich ein bisschen stutzig gemacht hat, da waren sehr viele Eier. Eier-Avatare dabei, die sagen, gut, der ist noch nicht so lange dabei und haben nicht so viele Follower.
Und es waren sehr viele dabei, gerade auch aus dem asiatischen Raum, wo ich mir dachte, okay, vielleicht ist Zebra-Tweets, das ist so ein Ding, besonders irgendwie im asiatischen Raum ist es sehr beliebt, eine sehr beliebte Kunst-Gag-Form. Und als es dann 2000 war, dachte ich mir, okay, jetzt wird es lächerlich, vergessen wir mal die Theorie, dass es an meinem Tweet lag und denken wir mal darüber nach, dass es vielleicht, dass ich Attacke, Opfer einer Attacke eines Massenfolgerungs oder so geworden bin, was ein bisschen schade ist. Vielleicht hat aber auch einer von euch mit dem grandiosen Streit gespielt, mir 2000 Follower zu kaufen, was wir haben nachgeguckt, vier Euro kostet. Das ist für die nie so viel. Und ich würde euch bitten, das zu
unterlassen. Um mir zu unterlassen, meine ich, Florentin, zehntausend Follower zu schenken. Ja, ein Menschenleben ist heute nicht mehr viel wert. Man kann so einen Follower einfach für ein paar Cent, kann man sich kaufen. Und gehören mir die Menschen dann? Da habe ich es verstanden. Ich habe verstanden, mir gehören zweitausend Menschen, über die ich einfach verantwortlich bin. Also ich sage mal, wir leben ja in einer Welt, also in dieser Unterhaltungsbranche, wo es, sag ich mal, schwer ist, sich selbstständig zu verbessern. Also angenommen, du bist Tennisspieler und du hast irgendwie in zwei Wochen ein wichtiges Turnier, dann kannst du jeden Tag trainieren, irgendwie, kannst dir einen runterholen, kannst irgendwie Sachen machen, dass dein Handgelenk irgendwie kräftiger wird und kannst einfach Dinge tun, damit du besser wirst. Wir allerdings... Spielst du gerade irgendwie Podcast-Bingo und versuchst irgendwie Wörter unseres zu bringen und du wusstest nicht, wie du anders runterholen und unterbringen sollst? Das frage ich mich jetzt seit zwei Folgen. Das ist gut, wenn man einfach so ... frage ich mich, warum manchmal diese Wörter in deinen Sätzen vorkommen. Und meine Theorie ist gerade in meinem Kopf gereift, du spielst Podcast-Bingo, du versuchst, wild Wörter auszubringen. Nein, aber du kannst halt verschiedene Sachen machen. Du kannst irgendwie Hanteln nehmen, du kannst irgendwie einen Krebskäfig versuchen aufzubrechen. Es sind verschiedene Dinge, die du versuchen kannst, um dein Handgelenk einfach stärker zu machen. Und da kannst du einfach als Tennisspieler gewisse Dinge machen. Du kannst auch zum Beispiel Zucker durch Süßstoff ersetzen. Das ist überhaupt kein Problem. Du kannst anfangen, irgendwie aus Amerika importierte Süßigkeiten zu essen, wie zum Beispiel Take Five oder Twinkies oder sowas in der Richtung. Du kannst verschiedene Dinge machen, hat sein Schicksal selbst. Twinkies, Twinkies, we love Twinkies. Hat das Buster abgelöst. Du kannst sein Schicksal selbst in die Hand nehmen. Ich finde nur immer die Momente interessant, wo man sein Schicksal nicht selbst in die Hand nehmen kann. Zum Beispiel Dates. Du hast in ein paar Tagen Date und überlegst dir, was kann ich machen, wie kann ich mich selber verbessern und gut auf dieses Date vorbereiten. Ich meine, ich kann jetzt nicht irgendwie mir noch ein Sixpack antrainieren in den drei Tagen, das funktioniert nicht. Was kann ich machen? Ich weiß, was funktioniert. Du musst dir zum Beispiel ein Pages-Dokument aufmachen oder Word und kannst dir einfach deine Gags reinschreiben oder einfach Anekdoten, um einfach was in der Hinterhand zu haben. Falls mal dieses berühmte peinliche Schweigen, wo ja, wie gesagt, habe ich auch mal in der Folge erzählt, bei Pulp Fiction ja gesagt wird, daran erkennt man wirklich, ob man zusammenpasst und freundschaftlich am Start ist oder wie auch immer. Oh, das ist sogar tatsächlich taktisch sehr schwer zu handeln, wann man strategisch schweigt und wann nicht. Habe ich auch schon mal gemacht. Ich komme mit Schweigen nicht klar. Ich muss immer reden, das ist mir aufgefallen. Aber manchmal ist es tatsächlich gerade auf einem Date effektiv, wenn du wirklich aktiv schweigst, wenn du das einfach aushältst und gerade wenn die Gegenperson Pulp Fiction gesehen hat, dann checkt sie auch, was damit gemeint ist und kann es vielleicht umsetzen, vielleicht aber wahrscheinlich nicht einfach, wahrscheinlich denkt sie einfach, du bist langweilig und hast es nicht mehr zu sagen. Gags aufschreiben ist schon eine gute Variante. Oh Gott, das ist so fucking erbärmlich, aber was ich tatsächlich gemacht habe.
Als ich auf dem Weg zu einem Date war,
habe ich ohne Witz
auf meinem iPhone ...
Und mit Date meinst du irgendwie World of Warcraft-Gilden treffen?
Ja genau, ich bin jetzt Disneyland gefahren,
ich bin in den Zoo gefahren und habe einfach erwartet,
dass ich da Frauen kennenlerne.
Dass ich da nicht Penguin kennenlerne.
Tatsächlich, Top-Tipp, nirgendwo lernt man so gut Frauen kennen wie im Zoo.
Wie beim Frauenarzt, ist mir aufgefallen, aber das ist eine andere Geschichte. Darf ich nicht erzählen. Und zwar, was ich tatsächlich gemacht habe, weil du bist halt, also ich meine, ich bin generell jemand, der versucht, sich ständig selbst zu verbessern, der versucht, wo kann ich irgendwie Dinge, wo kann ich mich gut auf eine Situation vorbereiten, bin leider in einer Branche, in der es nicht gut funktioniert, und auf Dates ist es schwierig. Was ich aber letztlich gemacht habe, ist, ich habe auf meinem iPhone mit einer App Gedächtnistraining gemacht. Ich dachte mir, die beste Art, sich auf dieses Date vorzubereiten, ist mein Gedächtnis zu üben, damit ich sozusagen als Vorgriff nicht mir irgendwelche Anekdoten aufschreibe oder sowas, sondern dass ich mich einfach sehr gut erinnern kann an lustige und interessante Dinge, die mir passiert sind aus meiner Jugend oder aus meiner Vergangenheit oder was auch immer. Habe ich wirklich Gedächtnisübungen gemacht und dachte mir so zwischendrin, als ich eben versuchte, so Kopfrechnen, so was ist 21 plus 68, so äh, ausrechnen, dachte mir, was zur Hölle machst du eigentlich, aber ich weiß es nicht. Deswegen ist auswendig Lernen ja auch so super und deswegen eigentlich ist der einzige Grund, warum ich ein Stand-up gerne mal irgendwie drauf hätte, auswendig ist, damit ich einfach immer was zu erzählen habe. Und dann würde ich mich einfach sehr oft auch unter fremde Menschen mischen, um dann irgendwie, stell dir mal vor, du hast wirklich dann irgendwie fünf Minuten Material, du kannst einfach fünf Minuten lustig Menschen unterhalten und du hast es einfach immer im Kopf, das ist doch großartig. Das ist aber echt so. Auswendig ist ja auch so großartig. Das ist aber echt so, was ich mir manchmal überlege, also gerade in Date-ähnlichen Situationen, ist, dass ich mir zumindest einen Opener überlege.
Dass, wenn es überhaupt nicht funktioniert, wenn die Chemie überhaupt gar nicht anfängt zu brodeln, sage ich mal, dass man dann zumindest ein Bild hat, über das man reden kann. Und ich habe das relativ selten gebraucht tatsächlich, weil es immer relativ gut ging, aber es ist echt wichtig, das zu haben, weil das einen auch irgendwie selbstbewusster macht. Und man weiss, wenn ich nichts mehr zu sagen habe, dann sage ich einfach, hey, sag mal, pass mal auf, sag mal, hast du auch diesen Schatten gerade gesehen, der vorbeigefahren ist oder was auch immer, was man sich überlegt hatlichen Situation rauskommt, wenn man ganz doll niesen musste und das Essen dahin isst. Das sind spannende weitere Anekdoten von Florentin Will. Bleib dran. Lass mich da mal ganz kurz ernst werden. Die Frage ist ja, auf einem Date, ist das Ziel, dass du möglichst authentisch bist und du selbst bist, oder ist das Ziel, dass du möglichst versuchst, einen optimalen Charakter zu erfüllen beispiel zu erfinden zu erfinden und zu erfüllen weil ja sag ich mal also beispiel blumen blumen group blumen group ist zum beispiel aus der aus dem impuls entstanden dass man gesagt hat ich versuche mir eine eine persona zu kreieren mit der ich dann auf dem date bin ich. Ich bin blue. Aber zum Beispiel Blumen ist ja das ... Ist da eigentlich eine Idee von ... Man sagt ja, I'm blue. I'm feeling blue. I'm blue. Traurig, ne? Ja, es schlägt da was hinter. Die machen mir immer so ein trauriges Gesicht. Ja, ich glaube vor allem, dass die Zuschauer sehr traurig sind, wenn sie sich diese fucking Show anschauen müssen, wo ich mir auch denke, hey, wirklich geil für ein dreimütiges YouTube-Video so irgendwie auf einer Mülltolle rumtrammeln oder sowas in der Richtung. Aber habe ich Lust, mir das eineinhalb Stunden anzuschauen? Nein! Aber das ist auch so ein Ding, was man fast verschenkt wird, glaube ich. Niemand geht frei, wenn ich so ein Blue Man Group. Es sind so Leute, die treffen sich da und alle wurden denen die Karten geschenkt. Wahrscheinlich das interessanteste Publikum von allen Publikums, die es auf der Welt gibt, ist einfach die Mischung der Leute in einem Blue Man Group, weil einfach alle einen Gutschein bekommen haben und da eigentlich nicht hingehen wollen, aber sich denken, ja gut, da habe ich auch nichts anderes vor heute. Und wenn ich jetzt die zweite Staffel Narcos nochmal anschaue oder einfach zu Blumen-Group gehe, warum nicht? Weil das versteckt da, was versteckt der Serientipp von Flo und den Will? Es ist einfach irritierend. Aber lass mich ganz kurz mein Beispiel nochmal ausführen. Blumen. Die Idee von Blumen ist ja, dass man Blumen schenkt, weil es unnatürlich ist, weil es für keinen Mann der Welt natürlich wäre, zu einem Treffen Blumen mitzunehmen. Aber das ist ja genau die Idee dahinter, dass man sozusagen sagt, der Mann verstellt sich und gibt sich extra Mühe und geht aus seiner normalen Comfortzone raus und versucht Dinge zu tun, die er sonst nicht tut, wie zum Beispiel Blumen zu schenken. Womit man ja auch nichts anderes sagt als, guck dir an, wie diese Lebewesen sterben werden. Richtig, guck dir an, wie sie langsam ersticken in deiner Wohnung. Ich will, dass sie bei dir ersticken. Und du bist die Nächste. Ich will, dass sie bei dir zu Hause ersticken, ertrinken eigentlich auch. Ja, kommt dran. Ist es für Blumen auch so gut, wenn sie sich schnell in dem Wasser stehen? Nein, bei mir ist noch nie eine Blume ertrunken. Das ist ein sehr unwahrscheinlicher Tod. Kakteen, glaube ich, eher. Ich glaube, einer der absoluten Tiefpunkte meiner romantischen Karriere war, als ich mich mit einer Frau getroffen habe, die eine gewisse Art von Blumen mochte und ich dann tatsächlich bei Kaisers im Supermarkt vor der Blumentheke, also sprich im Be bewegen es in einem Preisrahmen von 39 Cent bis 2,99 Euro pro Blumenstrauss, und ich tatsächlich mit der Google-Bildersuche die Art von Blumen gesucht hat, die sie mochte, weil sie das mal im Tweet oder sowas geschrieben hat, und ich dann die Art von Blumen suchte, weil ich keine Ahnung von Blumen habe, wo ich mir auch dachte, das ist so ein Bild, das mich ganz gut definiert. So einfach so Bildersuche, so was zur Hölle sind Margariten eigentlich, was zur Hölle?
Und ich habe dann auch tatsächlich die Falschen gekauft, muss man auch dazu sagen. Ich bin so ehrlich und sage, die Falschen gekauft, deswegen hat das auch nicht so gut. Ich finde diese Nutella-Pflanze nicht. Oh Gott, die war nicht so gut. Sorry, ich entschuldige, ich nehme mich zurück. Die war in Ordnung, nein, okay, es ist ja vielleicht ein bisschen die Awkward-Episode. Dann ist das Thema endlich vorbei. Das ist die Awkward-Episode, wo wir auch mal über Awkward-Sachen reden. Nein. Ja, mein Gott, vergiss halt, dass Dating nicht ein Thema für ist, ist mir schon klar. Gut, dann reden wir halt weit über die lustige Dinosaurier oder lustige, was auch immer, Sketche oder lustige Comedy oder huhuhuhu. Schaut, lass mich eintreten in die Welt von Stefan Titzel, der lustigen Haustiere, ironischen Instrumente und verrückten Alltagsabenteuer. Wow, toll, das interessiert die Leute. Mal einen echten Einblick, mal echte Emotionen, mal wirklich gucken, was im Leben der Menschenlohne ist. Was war denn da dann echt von dir? Das interessiert niemanden. Das sind echte Geschichten aus dem echten Leben, die interessiert sind. Nein, du hast dir am Schreibtisch ausgedacht, du hast dir am Schreibtisch ausgedacht, das wäre lustig, wenn du dich mit einem Handy vor die Blumen stellst. Das hast du dir am Schreibtisch auch, klar, nachts mit einem Whisky in der Hand, hast du das irgendwie in deiner Depressionen ausgedacht und erzählst das jetzt so, als wäre es eine wahre Geschichte. Aber in Wirklichkeit ist das doch so deine Person, die aussieht. Da wollen wir eine wahre Geschichte von Florentin Will hören. Es ist eine wahre Geschichte und ich habe tatsächlich auch einen Screenshot gemacht, weil ich manchmal von wichtigen Momenten mache ich Screenshots, wo ich mir dachte, so daran erinnere ich mich noch gerne, wie ich im Supermarkt stande um fünf Minuten vor Ladenschluss, weil ich es wieder nicht verrafft hatte. Hä, du machst einen Screenshot vom Leben oder was? Nein, von meinem Handy. Das wäre geil, wenn man den Screenshot des Lebens machen könnte. Das wäre geil, so ein Momentaufnahme. Wenn du das, was du gerade siehst, einfach anhalten könntest. Naja, auch das ist was, was den Leuten im Sims vorenthalten ist. Die haben einfach ein cooleres Leben. Fände ich auch im Alltag geil, wenn Leute mich einfach antippen würden und sagen, jetzt geht's im Kühlschrank und jetzt macht die Wohnung sauber und so. Aber man muss keine eigenen Ideen mehr haben, man muss keinen eigenen Antrieb haben. Leute machen das einfach für einen. Flotten ist raus. Ja. Okay, folgendes, ich habe eine Mega-Anekdote zu erzählen, die wirklich das Tiefste in mir zeigt, wie ich funktioniere, was alles schiefläuft in meinem Leben und die wirklich megamässig peinlich ist und es ist unfassbar. Also, wir fangen ganz vorne an. Ist das jetzt die Flüchtlingsanekdote? Es ist die sogenannte Flüchtlingsanekdote. Brauchst du eine Atmosphäre, brauchst du atmosphärische Geräusche oder irgendwas? Nein, ich versuche es mit meiner Stimme möglichst authentisch zu beschreiben, was passiert ist. Soll ich irgendwie so Ja sagen nebenbei oder möchtest du komplett freestylen? Nee, ich möchte gerne, dass du ein bisschen anekdotisch reingrätscht manchmal. Ich grätsch ein bisschen rein. Wo ich ein bisschen geckig mal zwischendurch was machst, um so das Ganze ein bisschen geckiger zu gestalten.
Weich, ja, kein Problem. Es war ein verregneter Mittwochabend. Ich habe Feierabend gemacht, etwas später als sonst, und begebe mich im verregneten Köln-Ehrenfeld in Richtung U-Bahn-Station. Plötzlich sehe ich in diesen ganz normalen Karten, die man an U-Bahn-Stationen sieht, wo einfach das U-Bahn-Netz der Stadt aufgemalt ist, ein Flüchtlingspärchen. Ein Flüchtlingspärchen. Zu sehen an den gross angelegten Taschen, die sie mit sich trugen, und dem syrischen Akzent. Und ich habe ... Bonjour, bonjour, merci.
Le fromage est très bon à Paris.
Und dann dachte ich mir, ich habe mir schon gedacht, als ich die gesehen habe, du musst nett sein. Das sind Leute, die haben eine wahnsinnig unangenehme Reise hinter sich. Und ich will auch so ein bisschen so ein tolles Deutschland, so ein schönes Deutschlandbild mal verbreiten. Also habe ich gedacht, lächelst die mal an. Die haben mein Lächeln erwidert und haben gemerkt, okay, da ist jemand, der hilft uns eventuell,
wir haben ein Problem. Sie kamen auf mich zu und haben in gutem Englisch zu mir gesagt, dass sie nicht wissen, wo sie gerade sind.
Good day dear sir, what can I do for you? Nee, aber die haben wirklich in gutem Englisch, haben die mir dann erklärt, dass sie nicht wissen, wo sie sind. Ich sollte ihnen sagen, wo sie sind und sollte ihnen sagen, wie sie am besten zu ihrem Ort kommen. Habe ich alles gemacht, habe gesagt, okay, ihr könnt sogar meine U-Bahn nehmen, ihr müsst nur noch mit mir fahren und müsst dann und dann da aussteigen. Das passiert alles, die Bahn kommt, ich steige ein, sie gehen ihrer Wege, gehen auch in die Bahn und dann fiel mir ein, scheiße, du hast den gerade in Station genannt, die kann so nicht stimmen, die werden da nicht ankommen, wo sie gerade hinwollen. In der Zwischenzeit, weil die Frau gemerkt hat, dass ich wahrscheinlich nicht so auf der Höhe war, es war ein Pärchen und die hat mir angemerkt, dass ich nicht genau weiß, was ich eigentlich sage und nicht nett sein wollte, weshalb sie in der U-Bahn die Karte aufgesucht hat und ihr Mann hat gewartet irgendwo weiter weg. Dann fiel mir aber ein, okay, wir sind gerade in einer Station, wo sie theoretisch an ihren Ort kommen könnten, signalisiere ich mal dem weiter wegstehenden schon mal, dass er hier raus kann. Ich bin also aufgestiegen, hat dem Mann gezeigt, hier, du kannst hier raus, hab dem Bild gestikuliert und die Frau, die bei mir stand, der habe ich dann noch erklären wollen, ja, und zwar, ihr könnt auch hier raus, wollte ich erklären, dass mir das eingefallen ist, dass man von da besser dahin kommt, wo sie hinwollen. Und das habe ich leider so lange erklärt, dass die Tür in der Zwischenzeit zugegangen ist. Aber war der Mann rausgegangen? Der Mann rausgegangen ist, was dann zu diesem Moment führte, wo sie mega fertig war mit der Welt und dann noch die Hand so auf die Glastür gelegt hat und sich von ihm film filmisch verabschiedet hat. Und dann ist mir folgendes klar geworden. Die haben kein Handy, die kommen aus Syrien, kilometerweit haben die es geschafft, sich nicht zu trennen, die haben mega, ich weiß nicht, die sind über einen Gazastreifen oder so, haben sich nicht getrennt, die sind zusammengeblieben und irgendein Dödel in der Kölner U-Bahn schafft es, die auseinanderzureißen und einfach deren Schicksal in die Hand zu nehmen und einfach komplett deren Leben gerade zu zerstören.
Die letzte Hürde vor Deutschland ist Stefan Tengel, der nochmal versucht, alles zu geben, um die Flüchtlinge auseinanderzutreiben.
Es war mir so unangenehm und ja, sie war völlig fertig und stand die ganze Zeit an der Tür und ich saß dann da und habe sie die ganze Zeit so entschuldigend angeguckt und habe auch ganz viele böse Blicke aus dem Waggon geerntet. Wobei, sie konnte dann auch irgendwann drüber lachen. Dann habe ich ihr erklärt, wie sie dann wieder zurückkommt. Aber es war wirklich sehr unangenehm. Ja, da will man mal mit sein und dann passiert mir sowas. Ja, die konnte irgendwann drüber lachen. Wahrscheinlich war sie diesem, die war so fertig, weil halt plötzlich ist der Mann weg und die haben kein Handy. Wie sollen die sich wiederfinden, die werden sich nicht wiedergefunden haben. Und hast du dann die Situation gesagt, jetzt wo du Single bist, irgendwie hast du mal. Das war alles ein Plan, ich wollte nur den Mann von ihr trennen. Das ist meine Art. Advanced Wingman Techniques. Illegal, illegal und sehr fragwürdige Wingman Techniques. Very. Very close to rape-Techniques with Stefan Titze. Almost rape, das Buch von Stefan Titze. Ist mir aber auch tatsächlich schon ein paar Mal passiert, weil ich die Situation immer sehr awkward finde, wenn man gefragt wird, wo man irgendwie hin kann. Und ich habe generell keine Ahnung, weil ich von Geografie und generell keine Ahnung habe. Ja, aber ich will immer Ahnung haben, deswegen erkläre ich immer eben, irgendwo hin, irgendwo, wo man die Donnerliste nicht kenne oder so. Was ich mir halt irgendwie, was ich mir halt denke irgendwie, dass ich auch oft einfach mit meinem Smartphone helfen kann, dass ich auch wieder die Karte aufmachen kann, irgendwie dann Tinder schliessen, YouPorn-App schliessen, irgendwie Shazam, selbst eingesungen oder lieb von whatever, von der Blue Man Group schliessen. Genau, ich weiss nicht mehr genau, ich sehe so dumm, dumm, dumm, dumm, dumm. Was ich tatsächlich sehr oft gefragt werde von Touristen ist, wo das Berghain ist, weil ich, natürlich, also klar, würde man sich natürlich an mich wenden, mit Geschlechtskrankheiten übersät, wo man sich denkt, ja klar, der Mann hat Ahnung, wo es Berghain ist. Und was ich tatsächlich schon mal gesagt habe, was wahrscheinlich der most badass move meines Lebens ever war, ist, dass jemand gefragt hat, ey, ich kam irgendwie wahrscheinlich aus einer anderen deutschen Stadt, also am Deutsch gesprochen, wo ist denn hier das Berghain? Und nicht nur so, da würdet ihr eh nicht reinkommen. Boom! No you didn't! Heißt natürlich im Umkehrschluss, ich habe einfach keine Ahnung, wo es ist, ja, aber einfach so, da würdet ihr eh nicht reinkommen. So ein bisschen diesen Mythos BerBerghain noch aufrechtzuerhalten. Wenn ihr es nicht findet, dann kommt ihr auch nicht rein. Ein bisschen von der Coolness profitieren wollen, die etwas anderes erreicht hat und sich selber davon bedienen. Ja, sehr gut. Hatte natürlich immer noch meinen Simpsons-Rucksack an und meine Garfield-Mütze, also es hat nicht so ganz ins Bild gepasst. Und dein Transformers-Outfit, du hast dich zum Auto getransformed und bist weggefahren. Ja, genau, und so ein Luftballon. Ja, cool. Weiß nicht. Wollen wir mal eine echte Folge aus einem Heissluftballon aufnehmen? Oder aus der Badewanne, habe ich mir auch überlegt. Sehr gut. Aber muss halt dann schon ... Vielleicht auch noch niemand gemacht. Also fändest du es unangenehmer, wenn man so aufeinander Kopf, also Bauch auf Bauch liegt oder Bauch auf Rücken? Ich fände unangenehmer, Rücken auf Rücken fände ich angenehm. Rücken auf Rücken, aber gut, er trinkt halt einer, ne? Ja, aber das müssen wir abwechseln vielleicht einfach, sehr lange Luft anhalten. Oder wir drehen uns einfach ständig so, wie so ein Kolben zum Motor. Nee, weil ich hatte wirklich eine ernste Idee jetzt mal, die ich mal kurz pitchen wollte, und zwar folgendes. Entweder wir machen daraus einen eigenen Podcast oder wir machen das jetzt in dem Podcast-Universum weiter, Podcast-Ufo-Universum. Und zwar, ich würde es Podcast-Lab nennen. Also wir machen und zwar, wir hatten ja sehr viele Ideen. Wir hatten schon die Idee, dass wir auf dem Balkon kommentieren, was gerade passiert um uns herum. Wir hatten die Idee, dass wir irgendwie kochen und Abend kochen und während wir das Gericht kochen, das Rezept verraten und einen Abend verbringen, dass wir immer den gleichen Film besprechen, dass wir die Stadt an den Fluss spielen und wenn wir einfach immer einen neuen Podcast, zumindest ein neues Format Podcast empfinden, aber nie in Serie gehen, also dass wir quasi immer Piloten aufnehmen. Ja, finde ich gut. So ein bisschen Everything is a Podcast Genau. So versuchen aus allem, was man machen kann, Podcast zu machen. Richtig, genau. Und es muss ja nicht, es muss nur eine Stunde tragen und wir müssen es nicht wiederholen. Und wenn was gut ist, kann man es ja trotzdem immer nochmal wirklich machen und als Podcast aufziehen. Aber ich finde eigentlich ganz geil, dass man halt eine Sache einfach eine Stunde lang durchzieht und zu gucken, wie es funktioniert und ohne, dass es irgendwie jetzt mehrere Folgen tragen muss. Das finde ich eigentlich ganz geil. Können wir uns überlegen, ob wir das so machen, als Podcast-Ufo vielleicht Special-Folge mal ab und zu raushauen oder ob wir das wirklich als ein eigener Podcast verkaufen, immer neue Piloten aufzunehmen. Aber wolltest du nicht einen Podcast komplett mit Siri machen? Ich wollte einen Podcast komplett mit Siri machen, genau. Können wir auch zu dritt machen, Siri, du und ich. Und dann kannst du dann Amazon Echo noch dazunehmen und wir gucken mal.
Wir versuchen die zu verkuppeln. Wir versuchen Siri und Amazon Echo zu verkuppeln.
Wie gut das denn wäre. Das ist doch eine gute Idee, oder?
Und alle sind angepisst, weil Siri nicht mehr ansprechbar ist, weil sie voll in Love ist und immer nur von Liebe labert und so.
Ja, nervig.
Siri, kannst du mir das Wetter sagen? Ach nein, ich schwebe auf Wolken.
Hier sind Bilder von Rosen. Das sind keine Rosen, Siri.
Das ist dein Penis.
Das sehe ich doch ganz genau, das ist keine, ach nee, oh sorry.
Ja, wie schaut es denn bei dir aus mit Twitter-Followern? Du hast ja jetzt einen grossen Verlust hingelegt. Wie denkst du weiter vorzugehen? Also was ist dein Kote-Plan?
Das Ding ist ja, ich habe ja beim Twitter gemeldet, dass mich sehr viele Leute gefolgt haben, die offensichtlich nicht existieren.
Warum hast du das gemacht?
Weil ich ein ehrlicher Mensch bin und weil ich Angst habe, dass Leute denken, ich habe mir Twitter-Follower gekauft. Das ist der eigentliche Grund. Daraufhin habe ich Herrn Twitter geschrieben und der hat tatsächlich mir gesagt, okay, ich habe die einfach jetzt gelöscht. Daraufhin hatte ich aber weniger als vorher, weil offensichtlich andere Follower von mir auch noch, andere Fake-Profile waren halt, was ein bisschen unfair ist. Deswegen finde ich, solltest du jetzt auch mal Twitter anschreiben, damit deine Fake-Profile auch alle gelöscht werden, weil ich finde, jetzt ist es gerade ein bisschen unfair. Das ist ein Ungleichgewicht, was da entstanden ist. Du meinst kurz vor den 10.000, dass ich dann noch meine ganzen asiatischen Freunde lösche? Richtig, korrekt. Aber das war tatsächlich auch so ein Punkt, weil ich, wie gesagt, also das gleiche Date-System funktioniert ja auch für Social Media, dass ich mir dachte, hey, was kann man machen, ich bin Moderator und versuche erfolgreich zu werden und man kann jetzt schlecht alleine im Stillen moderieren lernen.
Deswegen dachte ich mir tatsächlich eine Zeit lang, das Sinnvollste, was man eigentlich machen kann, ist, sich den ganzen Tag Fake-Accounts zu erstellen und seine eigenen Sachen zu liken.
Weil das ist ja gut, dann hat man viele Likes und die Leute denken, man wäre cool, obwohl man nicht cool ist.
Aber es ist im Grunde das Effektivste, was man machen kann, weil man sonst ja nicht machen kann. Ich bin jemand, ich will immer trainieren, ich beneide Leute, die in einem Beruf leben, wo sie halt konstant sich verbessern können. Und das kann ich halt nicht irgendwie. Nee, können wir beide ja nicht. Aber auf der anderen Seite doch, man kann sich kontinuierlich verbessern, indem man einfach sich Inspirationen holt. Zur Tankstelle geht einfach mal. Sachen erlebt, Erfahrung sammelt und das Ganze einzuordnen und weiss. Ich habe Folgendes gelesen, und zwar können wir mal kurz ein bisschen Nerd-Themen mal wieder ansprechen. Wir waren in dieser Folge, fand ich ein bisschen zu offen, ein bisschen zu lebensnah. Wir müssen mal wieder ein bisschen uns von den Zuhörern entfernen. Nerd alert! Folgendes, bei Star Wars, Luke und Leia sind Zwillinge. Sie sind gleichzeitig geboren worden, heißt das ja. Jetzt hat aber irgend so eine, die Studenten, die irgendwie Astrophysik studieren oder so, haben halt ausgerechnet, gut, da die ja immer auch mit Lichtgeschwindigkeit und so gereist sind, können die nicht gleich alt sein, weil nach Einstein ist man ja, es vergeht die Zeit langsamer, wenn man schnell reist.
Fand ich mega spannend, das ist natürlich Fiction und es ist völlig egal, dass sie eigentlich mega unterschiedlich alt sein können,
aber ich fand das ein ganz nettes Gedankenexperiment und ganz cool, dass sie das mal ausgerechnet haben.
Und dann haben die wirklich mega, sich mega viel Arbeit gemacht, haben alle Filme und alle Geschichten, die es über die gibt, niedergeschrieben, um zu gucken, wann sind die, wie schnell gereist, wohin und wie lange. Und herausgekommen ist, dass Luke irgendwie knapp zwei Jahre nur älter ist. Also es ist einfach das unspektakulärste Ergebnis rausgekommen. Wie viel Gedächtnistraining hätte man in der Zeit machen können, wo sie das alles zusammen gesammelt haben? Ja, sehr uncool. Aber da dachte ich mir auch, ist es jetzt irgendwie, also was versprechen die sich jetzt davon? Also es hätte ja etwas Geiles rauskommen sollen. Und was denken die jetzt im Nachhinein, haben sie ihre Zeit verschwendet? Also hätten die die Zeit, die sich jetzt da rein investieren können, nicht vielleicht anders investieren können, hätten sie was Besseres herausfinden können? Das ist wahnsinnig traurig, sowas. Und dann denkt man auch, dann zweifelt man auch am Schicksal und denkt sich, ist das wirklich das, was wir hätten machen sollen? War das für uns bestimmt? Wow, das war eine schöne Überleitung. Tatsächlich der Punkt, wo ich mal an Schicksal geglaubt habe für einen kurzen Moment, war, als ich von meinen In-Ear-Kopfhörern diesen Gumminöppel verloren habe und dann tatsächlich am selben Tag, als ich ihn verloren habe, auf der Strasse so einen In-Ear-Gumminöppel gefunden habe. Du, du, du, der Podcast-Ufo, du erzählst die Anekdote schon das zweite Mal, Alert. Ja, ich weiß, aber ich finde, die passt einfach gut. Und wenn wir jetzt einfach unsere ... Ich finde, das sagt sehr viel über uns aus, dass wir ... Eine der zwei Geschichten, die wir schon mal das Doppelte mal erzählen, ist, wie du einen Gumminöbel verlierst. Das ist schon sehr bezeichnend für uns, dass das die Geschichte ist, die wir doppelt erzählen. Ja, wir sind beide heute nicht so gut drauf. Ich bin tatsächlich heute sehr schlecht drauf, aber ... Möchtest du denn mal erzählen, warum? Ja, nee, ist glaube ich nicht so cool, aber ich glaube, es lief ganz okay dafür. Also ich habe mir echt überlegt, ob es überhaupt funktioniert, dass ich heute überhaupt performen kann. Ich glaube, es war nicht so gut wie sonst, aber ich bin relativ stolz auf mich, dass ich es trotzdem einigermaßen hingekriegt habe. Ich bin auch stolz auf dich. Dankeschön. Ich bin auch stolz auf dich. Und ja, was machst du heute noch so? Was ist heute deine letzte Angestaltung? Schaust du dir in die Magazin an wahrscheinlich, heute ist Donnerstag? Ich werde heute mit meinem Fisch eine Runde joggen gehen. Weiß ich nicht genau. Habe auch noch keine Bilder geschickt. Und mein Snapchat-Name ist ... Ich habe schon Beschwerden bekommen, dass du deinen Fisch noch nicht gepostet hast. Warum kommen Beschwerden, die mich betreffen, noch nicht immer bei dir an? Ich habe einfach einen guten Draht zu dir, denken die Leute. Einen besseren als du zu dir selbst. Ja, es ist halt schwierig, Leute, es ist halt oft so diese gute, schlechte Podcast, gute Podcast-Thema. Ja, aber es ist halt auch nur mal so, dass wir nicht jede Woche auch mega gut jetzt performen können, weil ich gebe zu, es war keine gute Woche für mich. Es ist sehr viel, es ist gestern, wenn mein Fisch fast gestorben, weil er sich seltsam gegen Eichhörnchen gekämpft hat. Ja, weil er irgendwie, ich weiß nicht, gegen eine befremdete Gang gekämpft hat oder so, das ist Kampffisch halt. Der hat halt manchmal auch so Business am Laufen, wo ich da nicht unbedingt Teil von sein will. Und der ist fast gestorben, weil er irgendwie Filterprobleme hatte, weil er da irgendwie reingeschwommen ist, weil er ein dämlicher Fisch ist. Und das sind auch so Dinge dann, die anderen runterziehen. Und dann kann man auch vielleicht nicht unbedingt die beste Folge raushauen überhaupt. Aber ich denke, ihr habt das Nachsehen. Bei wann seid ihr schon mal perfekt immer in eurem Job? Richtig. Lasst euch uns einfach als Vorbild dastehen, dass man nicht immer super sein muss. Man kann auch mal mittelmässig sein. Es ist völlig in Ordnung, wenn man auch mal mittelmässig sein kann. Ja, trotzdem spendet für diesen mittelmässigen Podcast. Ja, gebt uns trotzdem Geld und kauft unser Album und kauft unsere T-Shirts. Trotzdem bitte gebt dafür Geld aus. Wir brauchen Geld, wir wollen nach Hamburg, wollen uns dann Rocket Beans. Empfehlt uns und sagt uns weiter. Das wird übrigens klappen. Also jetzt wird es keine neue Basel-Enttäuschung, sag ich mal, das Basel-Saster, sondern das wird das Hamburg-Euphoria. Nope. Es wird tatsächlich funktioniert und Hamburgium, Hamburg-Takel, Hamburg-Takel, der Hammathon und der wird grossartig. Der Hamburg-Hammer. Der Hammerburg.
Alles da. Gut, vielen Dank für die Aufmerksamkeit. Bis zum nächsten Mal.
Vielen Dank an Stefan Titzer, der mir wieder bei geschickt hat. Und ansonsten bis nächste Woche.
Und vielen Dank an Florentin.